على الرغم من أن البلاد أنفقت على
الرعاية الصحية أكثر من أي وقت مضى، إلا أن صحتنا العقلية
تتدهور بشكل مطرد ومحزن
منذ عقدين من الزمن،
عندما ضرب الوباء، علمنا أن تأثيره
سيمتد إلى ما هو أبعد من
صحتنا الجسدية، الفيروس، العزلة، فقدان
الأحباب.  كان الأمر مثل رمي الغاز
على لهب مشتعل بالفعل. أنا
قلق للغاية بشأن أطفالنا لأن
هناك وباء، إذا صح التعبير، من
تحديات الصحة العقلية التي
يواجهونها أحدث الأرقام، حيث يقول حوالي 42
بالمائة من طلاب المدارس الثانوية إنهم
يشعرون بالحزن باستمرار  أو ميؤوس منها،
ارتفعت هذه النسبة إلى أكثر من 50 بالمائة منذ عام 1999.
نحن نبكي، ونحزن على فقدان
طالب من أحد أقران أفضل صديق
لابنة، وقد وجد استطلاع حديث أن
أكثر من 40 بالمائة من الطلاب الجامعيين
فكروا في ترك الدراسة إلى حد كبير بسبب ذلك.
من الصحة العقلية والضغط العاطفي،
أبلغ 41% من الطلاب الجامعيين عن
اكتئاب عام، وأبلغ 14 عن
أفكار انتحارية خلال العام الماضي
عندما سمعت عن الحالة الأولى التي
أصابتني بالفعل، ثم حدث آخر،
ثم حدث آخر، ثم
حدث آخر بالأمس، وأنا فقط  لا
أعرف ماذا أفعل بعد الآن
بينما اعتدنا أن نسمع من
الجراح العام عن أشياء مثل
التدخين أو المواد الأفيونية،
وقد اجتمع جميع الجراحين الأحياء
معًا هنا في دارتموث
لمواجهة ما يقولون إنه الآن أحد
أكبر تحديات الصحة العامة  من
الصحة العقلية في عصرنا وخاصة بين هذا
الجيل الأصغر سنا، ويجب أن أنظر إلى
المراهقين الثلاثة كل يوم وأعلم
أنني لا أعطيهم عالما أفضل
في العالم الذي ترك لي
والكثير من ذلك بسببنا  الفشل في
التركيز حقًا على الصحة العقلية والقيام
بالأشياء الصعبة التي سيتطلبها
التغلب فعليًا على
أزمة الصحة العقلية هذه، ونحن في
نداء كلاريون لنأمل أن نحمي
مستقبلنا